foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys where we are currently
off the Record very nice oh my God all
right we got our Fred AC in the Discord
who asked a pretty cool question I
thought was interesting are we finally
gonna talk about who is the hottest
Asian man alive right now go I mean now
we have no I'm just here
we could do that no no I don't wanna
that was for the next one but we could
do that now no no no no no no we might
as well it's just funny it's just funny
for like a joke for like a three minute
joke but I don't want 20 minutes of it
can we do like see don't want to do that
can we talk about how simulu is like
typically the first Asian actor ever
technically
what is happening let's just go back to
the first topic which one was that one
he didn't ask it yet I [__] it up so
this is the one that AC
um wanted to know what is your
relationship with your partner's family
oh do you hate them
okay I want to tell you guys out then my
mom says that when you choose your
partner for long term and if you plan on
marrying them she goes
look at their family
you're marrying their family
and then she goes and then it's like can
you be a part of their family too and I
was like damn that's some profound [__]
how do you even know this stuff when you
had a horrible marriage and your divorce
and you [__] suck at relationships
actually you know what I actually tell
people you marry your co-workers
and you're actually uh no no yeah you
marry your co-workers and you work for
your family that's what I tell people
but I think that's why it's so important
and that's why people have no hope and
that's why people cheats not the reason
why I say that is because people when
they have problems with their spouse who
do they ask advice they're co-workers
okay co-workers are dumb as [__] and
they don't have good relationships
they're gonna [__] your [__] up other
way around that's true if your
significant other isn't a hustler and
you're trying to be really
entrepreneurial they're gonna bring you
down how many people because you're
bouncing ideas off they're your
soundboard you know what I mean how many
people have ruined their relationships
because they have a idiot group of
friends that's very true yeah in fact
give them the shittiest advice ever but
I'm gonna give him one more chance
though
yeah two black guys but maybe next time
you won't have uh you can't open
biological you can possibly have three
black guys so yeah so what's what's your
relationship with your partners like so
back so I think the hottest Asian guy is
so so yeah
the cool thing is
I never met Hannah's family yet but I
[__] love her parents and I chat with
her dad like every day that's really
really cool every day yeah almost every
day we DM like through text yeah we we
[__] slide into each other's DMS all
the time and he teaches me about like
like like football which is soccer in
the UK he tells me about like that he's
been to the States before and you're
genuinely interested in these things
you're not like I think it's fascinating
because we're into the same [__] like we
like business we like like history we
like uh cultures we like a lot of
different differences and since he's
been in the states like he worked um he
had his own business like doing some
kind of [__] I forgot what it was
exactly but he came to Texas are you
talking to him every single day
I didn't get into his business yet but
but what I did get into was his
experience in the states uh and the the
the differences in culture and just what
he witnessed out here and he's really
into cars and driving and [__] like I've
never like talk girls and stuff hell no
dude but we do roast Hannah together and
that's my that's very good group chat
with her and her dad no we just talk
[__] behind her back oh that's bad
that's effective that's way better and
her mom's just sweet like she just she
just always for different holidays or
whatever she'll she'll you know hit me
up and I think like
we'll have American holidays like
American Mother's Day is different from
UK Mother's Day or just different kind
of stuff right so I think she doesn't do
it for like Thanksgiving like Happy
Thanksgiving or I was just like that's
so interesting she's trying to like
connect and be nice about Michael yeah
but then even I'm just not like
Thanksgiving is cool but I don't know
he's like how about those Enderman caps
does she hit you up and go like congrats
on Independence Day you [__]
don't be funny
scumbag
that's pretty cool that's unique I think
and then um I'm I'm gonna be I'm gonna
meet them soon oh face to face huh yeah
and then my because it all happened
because my mom was like I'm gonna be in
um I'm gonna be in the UK
says I'm gonna be on a cruise and I want
to meet them and I'm like you ain't
gonna [__] meet them before I do and
then she's like she's like why don't you
come through and I'm like [__] maybe I
will and then uh why don't you come
through yeah
she's like pull up she's like I'm gonna
be there
yeah and it's Ohana told her family and
they're like yo let's [__] do this
[__] so like Also let's [__] do this
[__] you sound really cool that's pretty
cool though
everyone's old ass [__] dude like this
might be the only time we all get to get
to be together as a family and just be
like hey what's up you should say that
to them one word there yeah you guys are
all there you should make sure it has
anything yeah you guys are all old as
[__] this might be the last time we see
each other
people love hearing you're [__] dude
you're like tales of the crypt keeper
right now like that's door
restaurants big enough to fit everyone
over there I don't know man we might
just be chilling at a park bench oh
all right pubs are like hallways in
there yeah yeah and then and then I
don't know like we just kind of gets to
see her family member she hasn't seen
them in like a year or so then we're
just gonna hang out you know she got
some we all got [__] dying ass family
members so I think this is gonna be a
good time for everybody to get together
yeah have you met her brother let me
tight I didn't mean any of them whoa
none of them not even once but they
they're so cool and they've accepted me
um so so nicely you know yeah sir did uh
Nina's Filipino family accept you pretty
easily Anthony
uh the sisters were uh they gave me a
little bit of a harder time for sure I
think she's also the baby so you know
what I mean just like like they try to
fake sister yeah big sister a little bit
you know and then you know maybe it's
because I don't know I was like a dancer
who was online or anything like that too
just like out of a protective nature
trying to play my sister yeah you know
what I mean just kind of a little bit
more like chin up like you know like
what's your intentions
but her mom is like one of my biggest
fans and supporters she subscribes I
mean she knows everything that I do so
she sees these for you guys and she
knows all of your names she watches this
show she's subscribed who's her favorite
of all of us definitely not you uh she
doesn't know about your good content
abilities yet though does she think I'm
Mexican what did she say about the
Filipino uh she's probably watching
right now
um she subscribes to everything she
every single time I come over she's
already asking like how's this person
doing teaching in this country oh like
are you guys going to rehearsal because
I know that this person is missing
because of this and you're like she
never asked she knows the Skins bro like
what is this Bart always says your sex
however
[Laughter]
to the meaning there what is the meaning
that she watches the show she knows
exactly what the [__] that means uh she
knows that my that's why I'm always kind
of slightly discomfort laughter
everything regarding those times
because you're a gentleman dude yeah
damn uh but no she's really uh always
been like a a suite of just support of
everything that I do and stuff like that
and welcome you right away
um but maybe that's also why the sisters
wanted to kind of like be a little bit
more like oh yeah but I I you know now
that it's obviously like the knots tied
and everything like that it's it's great
like I feel very you know comfortable
and close with a lot of them
um from like an actual personality point
of view like of her she's got three
older sisters that are like are half
sisters from like a different dad
but her next oldest one up is actually
only two years older than me like my
sister's age so I feel like
generationally like there's there's
relatability there and just things that
we you know it's easy to find Common
Ground her next oldest sister from there
maybe um the middle sister of those
three I maybe have like the least
connection with but like she also has
like the cutest daughter that like I
[__] love sweet her man too is like
one of the nicest dudes like ever and so
we just [__] love that guy so you
know that connection's really cool and
then her oldest sister is like a Gemini
who like is the only one in the family
who likes to drink just like me so
anytime we pull up to family parties
it's just me and her immediately to like
the [__] bar so like our ability to
connect is like super super cool and
I've stayed at her house in Maui she
lives in Maui and stuff like that so
damn that's cool let's go really
comfortable and then her dad her dad is
Nina's dad is the only
um Nina's her uh his actual daughter
because he's the the one that came well
I see I see okay yeah so she's a
treasure then yeah so the fact that like
I'm actually you know the man that's
taking care of her daughter now me and
him have a very like specific Bond as
well like I you know that like he the
way he expresses his like love and care
for me too is just like a whole other
level that like I'm just super thankful
for so I feel really lucky with their
family I really love her family too they
accept you immediately or was he like At
first I wanted you to be Pinoy no he's
he's a real cool he put on my daughter's
heart his name is Rocky he used to be a
DJ he was in the World Series of Poker
back in oh [__]
but he kind of got semi scammed for it
it was a whole thing and and you know
all this stuff
he kind of had some like alcoholic
spouts and stuff like that he's admitted
this stuff in the [__] uh can you
just podcast hilarious speech when he
like gave a speech at me and he was like
a family dinner that when my family hit
their family came together for the first
time for dinner
um but he's just he's just a cool guy
wears a leather jacket all the time
sometimes post [__] selfies on
Facebook does like live uh like DJs live
streams his DJ stuff for people in the
Philippines goes back to the Philippines
where he used to spin uh every now and
then and like does like private parties
and stuff so he's like he's hip he
sounds cool as hell sounds very Filipino
does he have a DJ name this is DJ Rocky
I mean if his name's already that's kind
of cool it's a great DJ that's so cool I
feel really lucky
um cool man yeah I love it I don't think
we've ever heard too much about how your
uh wife's family is with you and that's
it we're not going to talk about it
well to his family is they're really
[__] cool but did they like you
immediately
okay it's so funny it's so funny how our
stories go back to this but the first
time I met Tiff's mom was at the prom it
was like when I picked her up at the
prom when you're that you're the problem
[__] of 1950s dead
it was before we even left to the
problem
you're knocking on the door you got a
[__] robot we're all we're all the
whole prom party or whatever was like
meeting at someone's house and we took
pictures and [__] and uh I met Tim's mom
there
uh and her dad and her mom was like Hey
like if you do anything I'ma [__] you up
she said that she was like I'm gonna hit
you with this part like she was like
just and I was like I was like I was
like yeah of course I'm not gonna do
nothing did she look at the out the
window Go China no she knew I was a
cheetah oh but besides that like that
was the only thing like that was the
only time we've ever had knock on wood
hopefully nothing else happens but but
that was the only time where she had any
type of not confrontation it was more
playful but it was definitely like you
know she was serious she has that look
and she she kind of reminds me a lot of
my mom so I kind of already know how to
like like see her yeah but for the most
part she's been great she's she's uh
been always really nice to me there's an
ongoing joke that like Tiff has that
whenever I'm around the house her little
sister and her mom or other best
behavior when I'm around the house like
they're extra nice wow today's video is
brought to you by Sunday do you need
help with lawn Improvement yes check it
out this thing is actually made for
droughts so it saves water and this box
right here covers 5 000 square feet you
know how big that is it's pretty awesome
the size of a whole basketball court and
you could fertilize your whole Yard Man
and you know what's cool is less than
the time it takes to watch your favorite
TV show you could get this whole thing
done real quick all you need is a hose
you attach this whoops on this side you
attach this whoosh with the holes on
that side and you spray and make sure
that your lawn is well fed with
delicious fertilizer yeah and they only
use ingredients that you care about so
none of that harsh stuff you know you
don't gotta worry about your pet turtles
turn into Ninja Turtles you got only the
good stuff and you just put it in like
Jose says and look you got weed control
I mean these are other products but they
have weed control pest control lawn
repair there your whole One-Stop shop
for lawn care Sunday is easy and
affordable some lawn care services
actually cost more than fifteen hundred
dollars a year but Sunday's full season
plans start at just 109 and for a
limited time Sunday is offering our
listeners 50 off your first box so you
can get started today for as little as
55 dollars when you go to getsunday.com
off the Record at checkout that's fifty
percent off your first box at
getsunday.com off the Record they're not
nice to anybody else I don't know dude I
would expect you to walk in and all of
them are doing the Chinese eyes
yeah
nah it's funny because they don't really
yeah they don't do that stuff I wish
they would you're a nice guy right yeah
yeah try to be I try to make an effort I
should have her home on time yeah of
course wow you smash that night hey bro
I did it I did it did you smash the
night that you got married the first
time
yeah exactly there's an ongoing joke
also at the gym that boy like I'm uh on
anniversaries your boy always smashes
dude that's an ongoing show I think it's
a joke that's awesome guaranteed dude on
anniversaries I'm 13 for 13. my boy
26 points yeah yeah like just
but uh
it was great they're really fun we love
hanging out with them like I spent a lot
of time with them you guys like do stuff
yeah we spend a lot of time over there
you know and because she's the one
that's been taking care of all the
puppies oh right right she's she's the
do love all the the dogs that we have so
you know yeah other than that I don't
really have anything else interesting to
say about that I met I met uh Tiff's
little sister when she was like eight
years old so she's known me her whole
[__] life practically
22 now holy [__] so she's known me her
whole life and she's she's like she's a
sassy one bro so she like if somebody is
rude to her like she's not afraid to
speak her mind and tell people off she's
a little Rosie Perez huh kinda but she's
very quiet she's very to herself but
she's extra nice to me she's always she
gets advice with Tiff all the time and
I'm just kind of in the house like all
right cool I'm not gonna say nothing
it's all good with them so very cool
what uh tip's Dad yeah I'm cool with
them
yeah he's cool he's a quiet dude super
quiet like every traditional dad just
watches TV yeah it doesn't share his
feelings any type of connection at all
like do you guys talk about anything or
like kind of not not really actually no
not really I just say what up shake his
hand you know you just sit there and
watch TV with him yeah I watch soccer
with him or some [__] but most most of
the time is spent with do you understand
soccer not really because you know he's
been learning about it
as a kid I feel like everybody played it
as a kid and then you just forget I'm
just not really into it bro honestly if
I'm gonna keep it real I'm just not
really into it yeah it's it's hard but
they love it it's only it's really fun
during the World Cup though of course
the attention the idea of having an
entire nation on like somebody's back
for like a penalty kick or like that's
just intense the last World Cup game and
that was a fun thing because everybody
was like we have no skin in the game but
to watch them win was like oh [__]
Argentina right they won yeah you seeing
Messi get that that W what about your
family Bart what's up with your family
that's good
that's it
dude you're weird dude why am I weird
why am I weird oh you're about your uh
so Geo's dad's dad is that yeah wow
thanks a lot Nick
about his dad now yeah we got a great
relationship right you know really
[__] Nick man way to make it [__]
down dude it's a really great
relationships about Joe's dad while
we're at it I know looks like hey let's
trade dad stories
here we go
no but Jill's dad's like that too he's
kind of like this like tough Macho
Hispanic guy so um and for me like I
always like I like to break all rules so
the first time I ever met him um uh Geo
said like the whole family kind of
tripped out because didn't you kiss him
yeah because he has like this you know
like the what are the handlebar mustache
he kind of like he has like slick back
hair he looks like a um like a Mafia
Boss like all white hair snake back and
he just has like this
to half your boss he's like this like
demeanor and the first time I'm like hey
Pop and I just kissed him on his cheek
and you just see him freeze like
my sons are money
money and I think but from that point on
I think I set the tone we're like this
was really hard he'll do whatever it
doesn't really matter she knows that
those are weird you know what's funny so
I think the the Asian dude like weird
dynamic lasted less than a week because
I think once they got over that I'm more
Fitness dude than I am Asian dude yeah
what we all agree I don't feel like yeah
like hey hey like like the cousins were
like hey buddy you want to [__] grab
a video
[Laughter]
it's not even like Asian is Just Fitness
that's cool
hey man he's gonna die but he eat dog
boy
the first day that I we brought over I
brought over Korean barbecue to make for
them after they were all eating I was I
always wanted everyone know this was dog
your first time eating
and then Julie now he's [__] around
for this guy's a comedian now
that's a good joke if you're an Asian
guy going to a non-asian family yeah and
bringing some food you should try it
with the dog joke dude that's chocolate
lab definitely try that it's funny
because all the stories that you tell
I'm like oh yeah that happens in my
dynamic as well too that they think
you're the fitness guy you just don't
tell funny stories as well yeah once
again I'm like oh yeah that's a good
story that's how you tell content that's
like those stories you're not the
Chinese guy you're the fitness guy kind
of well not really but yeah and uh
Jill's older brother thought I didn't
like him in the beginning because you
know like four camera we're on
he's [__] crazy right you know but
then like normal Gatherings I'm like
just the chili yeah that's so true like
this and it's like in the beginning like
Jill's brother would be like yo it's not
like me because like he's going [__]
crazy on the show
he goes no that's literally how it is
like this boring like robot until it's
like time to do it whatever yeah boring
robot
and then my relationship with uh Jill's
mom's really good because I feel like
growing up
um you know you watch TV and you kind of
have like this imagination of what the
All-American household is like and my
best friend across the street was like
that like their parents are together
they eat hot dogs the dad plays catch
they play sports and then I'm at home
doing [__] math and meditating like
but so I like my household was never
what I thought it was supposed to be and
then so going to Jill's mom's house
where she's like oh you want pancakes
it's normal like it's like just a very
it's like a of a really tight
relationship with her because I'm like
oh this is the kind of mother and
household Dynamic I always wanted as a
kid can you come over she's like want to
meditate
exactly you're like [__] your stained
glass window bread and what's cool is uh
the little nephews and nieces will will
tell me
um all the little stories that they have
with like their teachers and stuff
because they all know about like JK
and it's so like uh they'll be like oh
yeah my teacher told me like they watch
JK news and I was like oh [__]
and then or they'll be like
um what is she telling me oh yeah uh one
of the nieces when she was eight
they're doing like a national
um what is it called like uh like
ethnicity Pride day and then she goes
I'm Chinese
and then the guy's like you're not
shining my uncle's Chinese yeah but
you're not Italian
because she's Hispanic and like all
Mexican school like in Montebello
funny it's just like I'm Chinese
she's representing her culture
that's great it's like taika yeah that's
so funny that's good
how about you Steve oh dude I I've
gotten on Nikki's dad like from the jump
like I was I think just being respectful
shaking his hand looking in the eye and
like you know hanging out with him and
stuff it was big obviously I like sports
that was really easy we both like
football he likes baseball I think
baseball kind of whacked but I like it
if I can watch anything though I can
watch any sports really and and um so
yeah he's a doctor
just gonna have a daughter the Dodgers
when I moved to L.A so it's kind of easy
and then um yeah Nikki said I was the
only guy she ever brought home that he
actually liked and would talk to but I
think it's just because I gave him that
respect yeah the first night I met him
he did that thing of like the dad thing
of like you know hey like that's my
daughter like be cool and stuff and I I
was just like yeah dude like I'll be
super chill like um and I I think he
kind of just immediately saw that like
the way I treat her and like you know
just opened the doors for her all stuff
like that he just saw me do all what I
do and then Steve being Steve yeah it's
just too being respectful right just
doing the base level respect things
which like apparently is so [__]
difficult for some people
um and then you know meeting her family
was easy too because like
um she has the Filipino side and then
she has the the white side and then like
you know I'm like German in the [__]
Irish and [__] and so meeting both sides
everyone was like just raised in America
except for her grandma like who's like
from from the Philippines so it's just
like everyone's just super nice and
chill and then when we were doing like a
barbecue deck to for first like I was
meeting all them and they were meeting
me
um I brought like this dope ass barbecue
spot and I was like you know because I'm
like German I was like that's Jewish
kids that you're eating right now and
then they were like [__] you guys are
very alike in different ways huh yeah
and then and then I was like psyched
it's not it's not actually Jewish babies
but like did the white side of her
family like laugh extra hard yeah yeah
they were like oh that's so good like
look you got them laughs
classic man I think for um smacks family
it's super uh first time I've ever dealt
with this but like her her mom and dad
are very like hands off like they're not
really uh
it's it's almost like when I met them it
was like meeting just cooler older
people that she knows not really like
parents are they like those modern
parents that are just like we're gonna
provide but then you be your own person
because smack's kind of done her own
thing from like a very young age so like
she's over here over there they're in
Australia so um when I when when they
come here or if I'm over there and I'm
interact with them it's just like
chilling with cool people like her mom
is very young seeming and I can talk to
her about like she used to have like
Australian muscle cars growing up and
she's just like a cool like cool person
and she doesn't seem old so literally
hanging with her like is kind of
interesting because sometimes it makes
smack look less chill because her mom's
so chill wow that I'm like dude smack
relax like your mom's cool and she's
like no like but her mom's so like just
like laid back that it doesn't feel like
parental at all it's very weird very
different from like how we would be used
to parents being yeah do you have any
uncomfortable moments with them ever no
not at all like they're just so like
easy going her dad is very um like he's
kind of more the emotional side he's
very like soft and like very nice and he
seems more british-ish
um but he's very cool like he I mean
he's a handyman kind of guy he's like
like built their house that they lived
in oh wow those guys but he's not like
overly masculine to a degree where he's
like trying to intimidate you at all
like he's just super friendly fart in
front of her mom like how chill is she I
think if it flipped out she would
probably just laugh
that's nice she seen she comments
sometimes on like some of the JK reels
like so I know that she's seeing some
stuff but she's like she's cool she has
her own like she'll make little Tick
Tock sometimes herself like just to be
chill yeah it's really it's super I'm
not used to that at all like in how we
grew up like every parent seems like a
parent they just seem super laid back
old and boring and stressed with full of
rules yeah I'm more used to that yeah
but they're like her dad is very active
like he'll do like motorcycle trips
across the U.S like with his friends and
stuff like they they don't do things
that like our parents would really do
[Music]
foreign